you let him drink soda very rare oh okay
you want this
he can have a day yeah you know yeah
it's like with my fitness pal dog
when i tell about my fitness pal you
stand under 1800
what are you doing how many calories we
want doug
so the way fitness pal works is you
entering you're basically tracking your
macros yeah
in all your macros and how many calories
if you don't it won't get out of hand
yes it and i was really out of hand
you're getting pretty big papa
i know yep so i i it's at 2 500.
that's what you yeah what what should i
do i would love it i don't i don't even
get to you 25. you don't do any cardio
you don't what do you get i never i
never hit 2500.
i usually have like 800 or 900 left
that's good yeah that's usually what i
have left
i didn't realize how hard it was like to
get to the
it it's not if like if you ate you know
well i mean it was pretty easy before
you like if you just have like you know
when my kids want chick-fil-a i'm like
[ __ ] there goes my dinner
you know or like i'm having a crouton
for dinner it's like 1200 calories for
chick-fil-a also you get the fries
if you have a sandwich at chick-fil-a
it'll tell you 600.
it'll tell you on the my fitness pal
like hey this has a lot of sodium
sodium got a tract yeah isn't it great
though oh would you start
a livestream but i've been doing it now
for over four weeks but eventually you
just
like i still attract some things if it's
like a new thing i'm gonna need but i
usually kind of eat the similar stuff
those uh premier protein shakes that you
do bro
i'm changing my life with the food are
you losing weight yeah i think i'm
probably uh i don't know maybe two
pounds you know
still i just started like when i start
dude if you did two pounds a week like
four weeks what's up yeah yeah i've been
doing it for weekends in a month
what'd you say eight pounds in a month
that's good huge oh yeah and
when you complete your logging to tell
you if you keep eating this way you'll
uh for in five weeks you'll buy the
premiere
no it was just a regular mine doesn't do
that it doesn't no that'd be nice you
have to use a free trial for that
you'll probably have the free trial i
don't have a free trial because i have
the free trial when it does that for me
really track your calories christian
yeah yours should just be eat whatever
well i'm trying that's why i do it i try
to like
what do you what do you have is set to
what 2900 higher bubba
i usually hit him it'll be like i'm at
like five years 2900
yeah he's trying to gain weight though i
know but with your body you can hit 2900
yeah
oh i drink
oh i got into that magic spoon cereal do
you like it
[ __ ] sakes hey i got i got an extra
box for you what uh what flavor though
what do you like
i like the fruity and i like the frosted
oh okay so i got the fruity and the
peanut butter
no you don't like the peanut butter i
tried the peanut butter you haven't
tried the fruity and the frosting the
fruit brush you know about magic spoon
i know about it because i hear so many
people get sponsored by them
i've never heard of it and then our boy
mark obviously is fitness freak
that's how i found out he was like it's
like protein cereal use this
yeah it's like basically zero carbs zero
sugar might be three grams
high in protein yeah yeah like 16 grams
of protein yeah a little bit high in
protein magic
the frosted tastes almost 110 calories
in a [ __ ] bowl
uh 11 grams of protein 110 calories 11
grams of protein 10 carbs
0 grams of sugar dude the [ __ ]
[ __ ] grace it tastes
just like captain crunch does it taste
like protein cereal no no
no i'm telling you because you haven't
had it i haven't i've had six boxes on
my house for
two months now and i've always been like
no no no no but bring in a box
yeah actually i got one in the car i've
got which flavor though
[ __ ] i just want to try to see peanut
butter chocolate don't do it
i'm telling you go run and grab it if
it's if it's frosted or the fruity
yeah the fruity tastes just like fruit
loops really it's
really good that was my show that should
go hard in the paint
because a bunch of companies now are
doing that where they're making like
healthier
protein version snacks like they have
hot cheeto puffs but a keto version get
the [ __ ] out of my face with them
it's good really you want the real
cheeto